si fortuné et si désirable alors combien
de milliards vous représentez tous les
deux
je peux aller chez le coiffeur tu as
besoin d'une coupe de tout ce que tu
pourras me donner tant des sciences
un mouvement Duane pourraient nous
écraser en quelques heures nous voulons
toujours ce que nous voulons nous
voulons aller chez le coiffeur
tu as besoin de t'enflammer c'est ça
t'arrive jamais des fois de pas
comprendre tout à fait ce qui se passe
la situation est instable
il est dans le coin
et il est armé je vais avec
la continuité logique de ce business
c'est le meurtre c'est intéressant
d'être près d'un homme que d'autres
veulent tuer je me sens libre d'une
façon que j'avais encore jamais connu
libre de quoi
une autre région est déjà en cours
vous êtes une pièce d'exception seul
vous faites pas 5 mecs quand il fait
nuit il vous descendent direct scandale
le mec mourir et scandaleux
toi qui parle de liberté
c'est un jour de chance
fais-moi découvrir autre chose
tu sens le sexe
le désir de détruire est un désir
créatif
dans la mort c'est à vous seul que vous
voulez